we make way for Boomer Esiason NFL today
on CBS and of course WFAN morning drive
co-host boomer thanks for joining us how
are you I'm doing great day and great to
talk to you again and you know I was
comparing the situation's was I was not
comparing the athletes still to be clear
okay no I I guess some people out there
taking what I said about Joe Carroll
going to Cincinnati like LeBron going to
Cleveland as if it were the same thing
in terms of the athletes but when you
think geographically that Joe borough is
about two hours outside of Cincinnati
with in Cincinnati Bengals fan country
and LeBron was from Akron about an hour
outside of Cleveland going to Cavalier
country I think the situations are very
similar in aspect especially that both
will be the number one overall pick of
their respective drafts yeah I only had
that comment and I'm I was with the
other people who were critical of it
just say wait he's not the same as
LeBron going to the Cleveland Cavaliers
but in you know in context then I
understand what you're saying but I just
saw the quote there and I was like all
right well boomers all in on Joe borough
they're really all in on borough do you
have what's your biggest question mark
about Joe well first of all I've been
all-in on Joe borough's since he won the
Heisman and came and visit us on the NFL
today I presented him with a Bingle
helmet and welcomed into our
dysfunctional family so that was back
way back then you know the one you know
the only concern that I really do have
of him is that he did leave Ohio State
he didn't stay there and battle it out
with the way in Haskins and you know
personally I don't know the situation
that unfolded there I don't know
whatever meyer and ryan day were saying
to each of the quarterback so i
understand in this day and age
these players tend to go to that
transfer portal at the moment they feel
like they're not going to get a chance
to do that us from the old guard
couldn't do that we had to fight all the
way through so that was the only knock
that I had on him but the fact that he
was a point guard and he led his team
you know to the state playoffs he was
the all-state point guard for Ohio tells
me that you know he's a great
facilitator that he's a great leader
he understands the game how important
his position is and you know I do think
he has the personality that Cincinnati
desperately needs as a quarterback and
that's why I think he's going to really
be a success there and I think he and
Zach Taylor should mesh well together
and look the Bengals spend a lot of
money in free agency this offseason to
try to prove to him that they're an
organization that didn't to win
so hopefully that would be the case and
hopefully he's changed some minds out
there would you listen to a trade offer
if you were the bengals i wouldn't i
think its corporate suicide if they
don't draft them I mean like I said he's
- he's from Athens Ohio so he's - yeah
hours outside of Cincinnati to the east
a lot of his buddies that he grew up
with are all Bengals fans I mean this is
like the perfect situation that's why
it's a lot like LeBron - the Cavaliers
anytime or even like Patrick Ewing
coming to the Knicks you know back in
what 1985 so I just think there's a
perfect fit here and the Brown family is
not stupid I can tell you that and Mike
Brown has always valued a strong
quarterback presence on the team that's
why me Kenny Anderson and Carson Palmer
and Andy Dalton lasted as long as we did
and got paid what we did to play for
that franchise so it's not a place for
quarterbacks to go and I it's a place
for quarterbacks to go and flourish and
I and I think given the fact that they
gave the money to AJ grain that they're
going to have their full offensive line
back this year and that they have Joe
Mixon in the backfield I mean I'm not
saying that he's going to be Rookie of
the Year but he certainly will have a
chance because I think he'll be the
starter on day one talking to Boomer
Esiason NFL today on CBS studio analyst
of course a morning drive co-host on WFA
and is it more of a fear of taking - or
a fear of passing on to a do you think
in the draft I I think it's more fear of
taking him just simply because of the
injury history and then when you listen
to guys like Mike Tannenbaum and Mike
Lombardi just absolutely destroying to
it you wonder if there's some sort of
conspiracy thing going on between Nick
Saban and Bill Belichick to get to up to
the New England although I don't
necessarily know that the Patriots have
the draft capital but capital to do it
I I you know he's left-handed and I
think it's left-handers day here today
at the shows I have seen all your guests
I'm rooting for the young man I think
he's a terrific young man I've never
seen a guy that's accurate come out of
college I mean that's the one thing that
I do really love about him the injury
factor does concern me but you know that
could happen to anybody
so look what happened to Drew Brees his
last game in San Diego he came back and
had a Hall of Fame career with New
Orleans and Sean Payton so hopefully he
gets to the right place where he doesn't
have to get thrust into playing right
away that he can actually have a few
more months to protect that hip and then
come hit the ground running in 2021 I
was also wondering about this boomer
where I've talked to Steve Young about
it this left-handed quarterback and you
know these these teams are built for a
right-handed quarterback but how much of
a difference is it now in today's NFL if
you have a left-handed or a right-handed
quarterback you know I think it took a
while for the receivers just to get used
to me when I was playing you know I
remember Cris Collinsworth used to say
there was like an eight to ten inch
difference of where the ball comes out
of the pocket and you know sometimes
think it's a little wacky if you're not
used to playing with it but you know
these guys are so good and - it is so
accurate I don't really think it matters
you know the other thing about Joey he
throws what I consider and I describe is
a very catchable ball it almost like it
floats right into the hands of the wide
receivers now a lot of the wide
receivers there at Alabama were wide
open so we have to see him at the NFL
game and at the NFL level to see if the
ball does have enough jump on it I think
it does I think he's got more than a
strong enough arm and I think that his
accuracy like I said is really
outstanding so that's a I give him five
stars on accuracy I'll give him five
stars on his arm strength the thing that
I that I thought I hold back is the
injury aspect of it and that's a big
aspect I think for NFL talent evaluators
I had Chris Fowler on yesterday and I
said you know what was your reaction
first time you met Joe burrow and he
went
extremely confident and I said yeah
that's the first thing that jumps out
when you meet him in person and I said
well what about tua he said the ball
comes off his hand differently that he
and Herbstreit were talking about it's
just different and I said of all the
quarterbacks he said I'm just telling
you it comes off his hand different how
do you explain that it's just natural
but something that you know it's like
watching calimary it's like watching
Andrew Luck you know some of the great
players that we've seen you know come
through these drafts you know it when
you see it I know exactly what they're
talking about and and to has got a
beautiful just like a beautiful natural
motion there's nothing you have to
change and you know the one thing I
remember when I first got to the AFL
Bruce conflict was my offensive
coordinator in Cincinnati and he used to
yell at me all the time get your elbow
up get your elbow up because when my
elbow was down I would end up settling
the football and thrown it over guys
heads and he would work with me on my
motion and everything else I was trying
to do everything all natural so I had to
fundamentally change the way that I
would do things I don't think you have
to do any of that with this kid this kid
just was like born came out of the crib
throw the football and he just does it
so naturally and that's the beauty of it
and as far as the confidence is
concerned with with Joe Burrell
here's what I love about that he's going
to go to a team there's a perception
obviously around the Bengals and we all
get it but I'm here to bump that in some
respects because most of us quarterbacks
that have gone there had pretty good
careers pretty good numbers and I know
Andy Dalton didn't what at all you know
a playoff game but you know they went
there and Marvin Lewis was there for 16
years
so believe it or not it's somewhat
stable and they do take care of their
own and they will pay their own guys and
what they need is a personality just
like Joe burrow to walk into that locker
room when everybody knows that he is the
leader and that's what I believe will
happen and that's why I think it's a
great fit for the Bengals I'll leave you
with this boomer Odell Beckham jr. I
know that there was rumor that maybe
he's on the move to Minnesota and I
think subsequent reports have said that
that's not true but you know
with what happened with New York and you
being in New York like where did things
change for Odell Beckham and do you
think that he can get that back that
whatever he had hey Dan I think he hated
playing with Eli Manning and I and I
think that he made no bones about it you
know what he did the interview with ESPN
and little Lane right there
you know unable to say a nice thing
about his quarterback Eli Manning who's
revered here in New York is that's the
moment that it really truly went
downhill you know he pulled the antics
on the field going to get the fluids
before half-time even started or you
know lifting his leg until it I'll feel
like a dog on the you know on a pasture
so all those things kind of added up but
that one interview where he just could
not say anything nice about Eli Manning
I think was the end game for most of New
York Giants fans here in New York and
you know it's a combustible relationship
when you think about the two
personalities Odell and Baker Mayfield
so there may be some truth to the
discussion that he could be on his move
on the move again but then again I was
saying to myself I don't know if Kirk
Cousins it's good on what to deal with
know it Mike Zimmer he listen yeah Mike
summers not going to want to deal why
would you trade a head egg to get a
headache yeah that's why I find it hard
to believe what I understand was the pan
scan coming from Minnesota I can
understand if there was a possible
conversation I just don't see it
happening the New York team that will
make the playoffs first the Jets of the
Giants wow it's a good question I'm
going to say the Jets only because I
think there may be in a better situation
in their division right now than the
Giants are the Giants have a untested
head coach they have able to get
together they'll have a second-year
quarterback
I think offensively they're gonna be
pretty good but I still think
defensively they're probably a couple
years away from being what I would
consider a playoff defensive team buy
stock in Sam Darnell door Daniel Jones
you know what I buy stock in Daniel
Jones and I buy heavily because I just
think the kid showed more than I ever
expected
he looks like the real deal Sam I think
has gone through tough some tough
growing pains with the mononucleosis and
all that other stuff but I also think he
plays a little bit of a he needs to
refine his game is really what I'm
saying in the pocket he looks a little
nervous to me still and I think that
still bothers some of the accuracy
issues that he has so he's got to calm
down we this year will be a year that
we'll start seeing that boomer great
stuff is always glad you got a chance to
clarify the the Joe borough LeBron James
stuff we appreciate your time as home
boomer esiason NFL today on CBS